hi I'm Hayley Atwell and this is Ewan
McGregor and this is the wired bottle
complete interview is that a question
that people wanted to ask me who does
you and McGregor look like they want to
ask me who I think I look like boy why
haven't they got better things to do I
get Eddie Izzard okay Ricky Gervais I
mean they're both very funny and very
talented yeah different times how many
ways to spell e one there's a few ewas
how I spell it
there's EWTN and in this you en I need
to do phonetically so why are you w a n
yeah you learn and then II won or I've
earn or I get called Eugene quite a lot
like Eugene McGregor that famous actor
how did you and McGregor learn to sing
water woke up one morning and opened my
mouth beautiful music came pouring out I
don't know how you learn to sing I did
get taught to sing in drama school again
I've got really good singing coaching
before I did Milano's where did you and
McGregor go to school well I know that
he went to the Guildhall School of Music
and Drama where I also went feel just
connection everything you can tell my
our style of acting is your McGregor
have braces know add a little cleaner as
opposed to the train tracks yeah and
then members to be a bit like this how
long did you have this a few years are
there yeah not very long but I didn't
ever birth it
well you McGregor returned to Star Wars
who knows
I do you know or do you not really not
know I really don't know I believe you
well I really believe that's two less
because it's the truth I'm not sure I
don't know I'd like to okay
does Haley Atwell speak Spanish no not
even a little bit absolutely not nothing
apologies to my shame where the suspense
is Haley Atwell from I was born and
raised in London but my dad and his side
family are from Kansas City Missouri so
I'm half English half American hmm
how old is helium it can ask a question
like that it's a very rude question
generally no question let's move on can
Hayley Atwell sing yes I can sing in the
shower in the shower I like to sing Papa
can you hear me by Yentl I don't know
why it's my song every time I get in
this in the show Papa can you find me
and then not do you know what - mine's
an Annie song maybe far away maybe real
nearby that's my song okay
Ewan McGregor what is your new Gregor's
accent Scottish what is your McGregor
doing now press with Hayley Atwell for
the classic film Christopher Robin yes
what color is you McGregor's hair would
you say you like a dark blond dirty
blond dirty blond I think of it I was
born with bright red hair
ah so I've got red in my hair I didn't
and then but ready blonde rainbow okay
finally what is you McGregor's new movie
Christopher Robin boom okay is Hayley
Atwell
British part British is Hayley Atwell in
Avengers 4 not that I know of maybe
watch this space what is really well
like in real life gorgeous
what is Hayley Atwell doing now
promoting Christopher Robin would you
and McGregor is there more is Ewan
McGregor a vegetarian
no is Ewan McGregor a Rangers fan no
executes McGregor related to create
Ferguson no why would you be well
because you're both Scottish sausage
that's it yeah
most people are related to one another
who is you and McGregor's uncle ah Denis
Lawson is my acting Uncle Dan it was in
local heroes what most people know him
from
he was the hotel keeper at Gordon
Arquette in local hero and then
other uncle's okay okay Hayley Atwell
dubsmash I've done a dubsmash
competition with the cast of agents of
shields where we would compete with
dubsmash Wars to raise money for charity
so I managed to contact Miss Piggy Miss
Piggy wore my characters outfits and we
did single ladies together oh my god
it's really nice Hayley Atwell driver's
license photo when I was shooting agent
Carter the show out here I had to apply
at the DMV for my American passport but
I had to do it in between scenes so I
went dressed as Peggy Hauser Royals yes
I was invited by the Kansas City Royals
to throw out the first time did you I
did am I gonna strike it was it was it
wasn't a powerful strike it was still
just a strike but it was good it was
good yes I was asked to do it once but I
was told that you can get booed yeah
like people get herand yes I don't need
more booing in my life so I said no
Hayley Atwell glasses or wear glasses
glasses do I wear them maybe aa drink
from them what color is your favorite
kind of glass I like to look through
them wistfully mmm um on occasion when I
felt the Google searches were fairly
tame yes I know now I know what you'll
go to song in the shower yeah and I
don't know the words to it so I just
sing the same bedroom the bed by the
time the coffee oh yeah she may be
sipping his coffee he may be fixing her
time see that's wrong that's the worst
thing it he may be sipping his coffee
she might be fixing his tie that's the
probably what it is mm-hmm
[Music]